قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها نفذت
اكثر من 20 غاره جويه على مواقع للقوات
الروسيه كما دمرت مروحيتين هجوميتين من
نوع كي اي 52 واربع مسيرات من نوع شاهد
وواحده من نوع لانصت خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الماضيه افاد رئيس الاداره
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه خاركيف بسقوط قتيلين
على الاقل في قصف روسي صباح اليوم على
المنطقه واضاف ان عددا من المباني السكنيه
تضررت بسبب القصف في مقاطعه اوديسا قال
المتحدث باسم الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
استهدفت مستودعا للذخيره في منطقه ريكوفى
جنوب شرقي خرسون ما ادى الى تدميره
بالكامل في المقابل افادت خدمات الطوارئ
في خرسون المواليه لروسيا ان القوات
الروسيه دمرت مستودعا للذخيره للقوات
الاوكرانيه في الاثناء افاد حاكم مقاطعه
بالقرود الروسيه فياتشي لان مسيره
اوكرانيه القت ثلاث عبوات ناسفه على قريه
نوفو وفي دنياتك افادت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا عن مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه اخرين
بينهم طفل في قصف اوكراني طال المقاطعه
وقال عقيد في الجيش الروسي ان الطيران
الروسي قصف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه في
محور كوبيانس ومنطقه ستاروفيكا بثمان
ضربات صاروخيه وقنابل